[Music]
we still have flat earthers we have
people that don't believe in
vaccinations and what do we do about it
well first of all I think there's a gene
I think there's a gene for a
superstition a gene for hearsay a gene
for magic a gene for magical thinking
and I think that when we were in the
forest that gene actually helped us
because nine times out of ten that gene
was wrong superstition didn't work but
one time out of ten is saved your butt
that's why the gene is still here the
gene for superstition and magic now
there's no gene for science science is
based on things that are reproducible
testable it's a long process the
scientific method it's not part of our
natural thinking we have it's an
acquired taste it's like broccoli you
have to learn how how the power can be
unleashed by looking at your diet for
example so I think a thousand years from
now a thousand years from now we will
have flat earthers a thousand years from
now we will have people that still did
not want to be vaccinated okay so what
do we do about it
well it's a struggle it's a struggle
that's eternal because I think we it's
part of our genetic makeup okay and
there's even a name for some of this
superstition it's called pareidolia
what is pareidolia it's the idea that
when you look in the sky you see things
that are not there let's do an
experiment look at the clouds and try
not to see something there it's very
difficult you look at the clouds you
can't help it you see Donald Duck you
see Mickey Mouse you see snakes animals
you see all sorts of stuff you can't
help it
recently the notes raghava Cathedral
partially burned down and sure enough
somebody said I see Jesus Christ there I
saw the picture maybe you did too it
really did look like
Jesus Christ but it was the ashes of no
Saddam and how many times do people see
the Virgin Mary in a glass of of T so we
are hard-wired to see things that are
not there because for the most part
they're harmless for the most part they
do nothing and once in a while that
saves our butt and so that's why I think
we will have flat earthers we will have
the people who don't like vaccinations
because hearsay throughout human history
was the dominant form of information
sharing you know the Internet is very
new newspapers are behind you who
science and technology is very new but
classic hearsay slander rumors there's a
gene for that okay so how do you combat
it slowly carefully painfully it's a
painful process but in some sense we're
going up against our genetic
predisposition to believe in nonsense
[Music]